what's going on guys this is Rob and I
wanted to talk to you guys for a quick
minute just really kind of getting hat
get things hashed out with you guys I
can't talk um as you guys know we're
moving on like we're we're moving
forward with the whole Civil War thing
and I think we're actually doing quite
well with the videos we've only got a
couple out so far in terms of the full
story itself but we're really kind of
getting into like the real meat and
potatoes a civil war and I've been
thinking about this for the last few
days I've actually been thinking about
it since we finished Civil War part two
and my question is this how do you guys
want me to do tie-ins because the times
are gonna get expansive like an Emmy
right now in in part two and we actually
missed a tie and we missed frontline
part one so we'll have to go back and do
Civil War frontline and then kind of
jump past Civil War part two and we'll
do that in the next video but how do you
guys want me to do that do the times
because once we get around like Civil
War part for Civil War part 5 and part 6
and so on and so forth
the tie-ins are gonna be as high as 13
so we'll have like Civil War part 4 and
then we'll have 13 comics and then we'll
have Civil War part 5 and each of these
comics is 27 pages apiece and even if I
you know confined the amount of time I
spent in for each comic two three
minutes that still comes out to be 40
minutes like a 40 minute long video
about tie-ins and as much as I love
tie-ins for you guys the one thing we
got to keep in mind here is that there
are people who are still coming across
my channel there are people who are
still learning new things you know and
who are interested in watching this
video and they may not necessarily want
to see a 40 minute long video but I
reconcile that with the fact that I'm
here to bring you guys what you want to
see and that's what I'm doing that's why
I'm making this video you know I'm gonna
do my best to bring you guys what it is
that you want to see so here's my
question how do you want me to do
tie-ins would you guys rather that we
have a discussion on Civil War on Monday
and then you'd like the tie-ins on
Thursday you know would you guys rather
that we split the tie-ins in half so we
do the first half of the tie-ins on
Monday and then the second half and the
Civil War storyline on Thursday you know
let me know how you guys want me to do
that you know because this is the first
major storyline that I've ever done on
my youtube channel and so I want this to
really kind of be the template I really
want us to kind of follow this
a turn I mean this roads gonna be a
little bit rough it's gonna be a little
bit bumpy it's just the nature of really
kind of starting something new and I'm
fine with that but like I said I think
the videos that we've done quite done so
far or actually pretty good I mean I
think they're enjoyable and you guys
really seem to like them but the way in
which we do this video will determine
future story lines so when we get into
the house of M when we get into the
Secret Invasion things like that those
story lines will really kind of follow
the template that we've laid down here
with civil war and so I want to make
sure that the the method in which we do
these videos is something that you guys
like so that when we get around to so
Marvel or I'm sorry to the house of M
and the other story lines and like fear
itself and stuff like that but you guys
aren't going to be like you know why is
this so different you know I mean I like
the way you did it before you know so um
let me know let me know what you guys
want to see let me know how you guys
want me to do things because you know as
I've said a million times on this
YouTube channel I'm doing my best to
bring you guys what you want and you
know that the whole basis of this
channel is to give you guys the
information that you want in a way
that's effective and it doesn't really
do any good for anybody if I'm bringing
you videos in an ineffective way and the
way that you don't want to see them you
know I really kind of defeat the purpose
of all this kind of all this like the
whole basis of this YouTube channel so
I'd really like some definitive answers
I would really like you guys to tell me
what it is that you want to see because
again this is gonna set the standard for
all the future videos that we do when it
comes to major storylines and so I would
I'd rather you guys not post stuff like
I'm down for whatever you know because
that doesn't really give me an answer I
mean it's not really answering anything
you know I'm looking for concrete
answers I'm looking for definitive
answers now keep in mind you know if
only five of you respond to this and you
say keep doing what you're doing then
that's what we'll do we'll make these
hour long videos about civil war it's
not something I'd like to do just
because putting an hour-long video
together is time consuming that would
take me a week or two to put together an
hour-long video just between work and
and you know my personal life and so on
and so forth but you know let me know
you know give me some info yeah
give me some feedback here let me know
what you guys want to see ya the other
thing to keep in mind here is you know I
really kind of want to break away from
the civil war or civil war discussion
right now and talk about the whole thing
that's going on with my channel binney's
channel and Dave's channel so as you
guys know we mentioned this in the
podcast dave has started a new channel
as comics reviews and David's really
just kind of kind of take the road of
saying so you want to get into x-factor
for example and he's gonna really kind
of give you the comics to get into you
know the comics that he read the comics
that he thinks are the most effective
and the way to kind of introduce you
into comic books you know the main focus
here on this channel is to give you the
information you guys want to know about
Iron Man I'll tell you everything you
want to know about Iron Man I will teach
you about the history of Tony Stark and
we'll talk about his alcoholism and
we'll talk about all that kind of stuff
if you guys want to know which comics
you should read in order to start
getting into Ironman Dave will be your
guy Dave will be the guy that you go to
and you say Dave which comics should I
start you know where should I start with
X Factor Dave will give you the rundown
now my channel will do that to a degree
I mean it's kind of the you know the
basis of my channel you know I mean for
example we talked about spider-man I
said well spider-man first appeared an
amazing fantasy issue number 15 right
off the bat you know that's the first
comic you ever showed up in that's kind
of where you'd want to start but if you
want the entire chronological event of
spider-man if you want to know the best
comics of spider-man appeared in from
the perspective of somebody who's you
know purchase omnibuses
I don't know if I'm the Misses is a
right word who's purchased you know the
thick books of spider-man and stuff then
Dave will be your guy and and you know
me and and Vinny and Dave have really
kind of set this up intentionally um you
know I'm really kind of the in-depth guy
you know I explore the nooks and
crannies I get down into the
nitty-gritty you know and I explain you
know everything between you know all the
comics on the characters and stuff like
that you know I guess maybe think of my
channel is is like a wall you know when
you build a wall you've got bricks that
are stacked on top of each other well I
give you the bricks but I also give you
the mortar in between each of them you
know Vinny is really really good at
giving you guys a short concise
information and it's just really good
when you're on the run I mean if all you
really want to know is just a short quip
you know the Days of Future past
and eight or nine minutes Benny what
give that to you and he's extremely good
at that you know and Dave is gonna be
the Commish reviews guy you know we've
set this up intentionally so that the
three of us can really kind of be a
trifecta of Marvel and and you know
various I guess DC information but
unlike Dave and Benny I will not be
doing DC I will not be discussing
anything DC related on my channel with
the exception of whatever happens to
come up in the podcast if you guys are
interested in DC Comics stuff and you're
really only interested in spider-man and
stuff like that Dave and Benny will be
your guys I mean if you want to know
about you know what it was that I'm
sorry not that say spider-man before I'm
in Superman you know if you guys want to
know what the Hugh you know what
happened between the old-school Superman
that never killed anybody
and the current Superman that will kill
people Dave and Vinnie are your guys you
know I'm just I'm just the Marvel guy
you know the other thing that I want you
guys to keep in mind here too is that
it's not about who's better I've seen
you guys post comments about that what
you guys have said the Rob's better you
know or you know Rob has better videos
or things like that
neither none of us are really better
than the other I'm not better than Benny
when it comes to making videos Ben he's
not better than me when it comes to
making videos we make different kinds of
videos we make videos for different
purposes you know again I give you guys
the really really really in-depth stuff
that a lot of people just might not care
about you know Benny will give you the
run over he will give you the quick
explanation he will give you the details
in terms of the storyline itself but
Benny I don't think is gonna sit down
and say here's why 20 start we came in
alcoholic he'll just say tony stark was
an alcoholic and that's it you know I
like that idea I like the idea of having
you know three youtubers basically who
can come together and who can really
kind of contribute their ideas to three
different types or two kind of this
great big huge world of comic books and
I think the way we've become pretty
effective in that you know just in the
podcast alone and so you know of course
there'll be a link in the description
for for Dave's channel make sure you
guys check him out I'm not sure he has
any videos up yet he's in the process of
getting them together and really kind of
discovering you know exactly how the
whole YouTube stuff works but but the
three of us are really kind of trying to
get together put our heads together and
bring you guys some good stuff so you
know keep an eye on the future when we
bring any guys some good content
hopefully we'll be able to do some
crossovers with each other's channels
and stuff like that where you know I'll
feature bidding on my channel for a
segment Benny will feature me on his
channel for a second
we'll both feature Dave on our channels
for a segment or something along those
lines but you know again that's that's
what we're here for you know that's what
me Benny and Dave are here for we're
here to answer the questions you guys
have we're here to bring you guys a
content that you guys are gonna enjoy
and hopefully the three of us can really
kind of / you know I guess form this
trifecta powerhouse I guess maybe kind
of a comic book community that you guys
can really look at as a great source of
information and I have had here on my
tongue I have a cat and those of you
guys who have cats know like hair ends
up in the weirdest places in something
like your ear ends up in your mouth it's
weird and no I wasn't looking my cat but
anyway so so I'm gonna go and bring this
video to an end but yeah just to sum up
the finer points let me know how you
guys want me to do tie-ins let me know
if you guys want me to go ahead and just
do one big video with all the times and
then a video of the Civil War let me
know if you guys want me to split the
tie-ins up and you I'm gonna do one half
of the tires on one day then the other
half of the tie ends followed by the
Civil War on another day and and you
know me Benny and Dave are making
hopefully gonna make a really cool
community in YouTube for Marvel comics
so where I guess comic books in general
I don't know anyway yeah that's pretty
much it and yeah so I'll catch you guys
later peace